well let's now speak to Chris gunnes
who's a former unra spokesman unra is
the UN Agency for Palestinian refugees
Chris good to have you with us again on
Al jazer what do you make of this
resolution calling for scaling up
humanitarian Aid into Gaza as urgently
as possible and distributing as well are
conditions right for this resolution to
have an impact on the
ground this resolution is a green light
for continued genocide and to be clear
it's an American Israeli genocide it's
not just an Israeli genocide because not
just does America provide Israel with $4
billion dollar worth of Military Support
per anom it's also as we've seen tonight
providing Israel with diplomatic and
political cover to continue with a
genocide which is marked by the
wholesale and Industrial uh ignoring of
international humanitarian law
and to be clear from what the Israeli
representative at the meeting said
although the resolution attempts to
force the issue of increased
humanitarian Aid it's clear that Israel
intends as it's done in the past to have
a veto of over what goes into Gaza yeah
I was going to ask you about that
because many things still unclear I mean
the timeline of getting this increased
Aid into Gaza how much of it will go in
what will be the mechanisms of delivery
and so on has was that clear to you from
from the
next it's very clear to me what has to
happen and what has to happen is the
Karam Shalom Crossing from Israel into
Gaza which has many lanes many trans
shipment points must be open
247 and hundreds and thousands of trucks
need to go into Gaza every single week
there's no doubt that what we've seen is
a trickle and increasing a trickle to a
bit more of a trickle is not good enough
people in Gaza are starving amid a
genocide does the world the UN Security
Council really want to stand by why that
continues what what I mean you mentioned
K Abu Salam Crossing being open there
but even if it's the case that it's open
will it really change anything when the
Israelis are attacking even the
crossings that allow Aid to go into
Gaza well I'm been around long enough to
remember the whole debate over km Shalom
the Europeans built it with a huge
amount of money and Israel eventually
said it doesn't meet its security needs
it simply said that it was not possible
to protect the Israeli side and
therefore it closed and the world simply
stood by while Kim Shalom was closed and
my concern given the weakness of this
resolution that that will continue
meanwhile people in Gaza will be
continue to look at drinking uh sea
waterer starving it's an absolute
disgrace that the International
Community embodied in that security C
sitting around that HHO table in New
York can turn its back on starvation
being used as a weapon of war and
genocides it's an utter disgrace yeah
coming back to the text Chris it calls
for also the immediate appointment of a
UN Human of a humanitarian coordinator I
should say to to lead the task of
increasing uh the the flow of Aid into
Gaza but the US doesn't want the United
Nations to have exclusive control of the
deliveries us and Israel if not the UN
then
who well that's the major question isn't
it because we've seen humanitarian
coordinators come and go with with
almost no impact whatsoever we saw Tony
Blair as the quartet Envoy um we know
very well what little good he did how
few the number of checkpoints he had
lifted or moved in the West Bank so yes
I mean that is the big question and I'm
not convinced that anyone has the answer
and the real problem is that in the
absence of any answer Israel will
continue to use starvation as a weapon
of war and to pursue this genocide and
the big fear also is that what we're
seeing is ethnic cleansing which you
know if anyone is seen or what what has
been the case in the past the darid plan
the idea that Israel with will
ethnically cleanse the Palestinians the
big concern is that that dream of the
early Zionist is now being fulfilled at
least Gaza yeah and the world food
program Chris warning of a devastating
famine if this conflict
continues has it ever been dis yeah go
on please well for many Palestinians I
talk them even the young Palestinians I
talk to say this reminds us of what our
grandparents said about 1948 it's a NABA
but it's a NABA plus it's a acba plus
genocidal intent we've heard what Mr
Netanyahu has said invoking the biblical
genocide injunction we've heard what yav
Galant the Israeli defense minister has
said about starving out these animals
we've heard the Israeli cabinet minister
talking about dropping a nuclear bomb so
it's NABA plus and that is absolutely
terrifying for the Palestinians and it
votes very badly for Israel's security
and for peace in the Middle East more
generally Chris gunnis thank you very
much for joining us on Al jazer thank
you for your
time and